Communicating underwater is challenging.
Light and odors don't travel well...
...so it's hard for animals to see or smell.
But sound moves about four times faster in water than in air...
...so in this dark environment, marine mammals often rely on vocalization to communicate.
Whale songs are one of the most sophisticated communication systems in the animal kingdom.
Only a few species are known to sing:...
...Blue, Fin, Bowhead, Minke whales and of course, Humpback whales.
We don't know this for sure,...
...because it's essentially impossible to observe the internal organs...
...of a living, singing whale,...
...but we think that when a whale sings, muscular contractions in the throat and chest...
...move air from the lungs across the U-fold and into the laryngeal sacs,...
...causing the U-fold to vibrate.
The resulting sound resonates in the sacs like a choir singing in a cathedral,...
...making songs loud enough to propagate up to thousands of kilometers away.